foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
stodger Roan
oh my God what a great week this is
gonna be for America they are freaking
the [ __ ] out Rider stone is already
calling the videotape of the documentary
footage deep fake video
they they're in big trouble whatever is
on this video whatever the hell the
January 6th select committee is going to
show us tomorrow and we've already seen
a cue up of this from Don Lemon on CNN
where they aired some of the footage
that is possibly going to be shown
tomorrow
it's gonna be [ __ ] absolutely
groundbreaking folks
and the reason why you know this is
because Ryder stone is already out on
social media on his I don't know Trader
Social account whatever the hell this
wherever the hell he posted
it's already saying this is a deep fake
he's saying it's not real don't believe
your eyes
they're in big trouble
huge trouble here and the reason why is
because it's all premeditated of course
we know this
we know they premeditated this they were
saying it from microphones back then
even the Cheeto dust mobster but in
private they were giving the plans
in private conversations in front of a
[ __ ] documentary camera
and of course it's it's
classic Roger Stone
where he's all hopped up on something it
seems
and he's absolutely gritting his teeth
I'm surprised he has teeth left how many
how many veneers you think this guy is
bought
because he's ground them down to Nubs as
much as he grits his teeth and Jacks his
jaw
these people knew he was gonna lose
they knew he was going to lose
they knew they had to cheat to win they
understood that
there was no question the only way that
Donald Trump was going to win the
election was to steal it just like he
did the first time in 2016.
that's how they know
what are you [ __ ] you think's in those
documents that They seized
that he stole from us
it's Intelligence on him
I have no doubt in my mind now
no doubt in my mind
that Donald Trump colluded with Russia
to try to steal our democracy for a
tower in Russia
no doubt in my mind
and history will tell us
because now the government has back
their documents
we have our documents back most of them
they confirmed this morning that yes
there are empty folders yes he did put
ketchup and eat some probably more than
likely he destroyed or sold something
where the hell they go
you're telling me dude just stole empty
classified document folders just stole
them
I mean as as trophies are to stick in a
box in his office or scatter on the
floor or stick in his desk
look folks there are high crimes
committed here
Espionage borderlining on treason I mean
when you see this video
of Roger Stone absolutely Jack jawed
hype topped up on something and he's
ready to steal the election he's saying
it out loud
and this is not in some sort of [ __ ]
weird
situation where
he is not connected to the president
United States this guy talks to the
president
or did talk to the president at the time
talks to the Cheeto dust mobster as of
today
when you see this footage
he was being his sentence was being
commuted
to make sure he did not go to prison
for the president of the United States
at the time
who is an unindicted co-conspirator
in the conviction of Roger Stone
all teeing up as tomorrow as we watch
the January 6 elect committee gonna
absolutely burn down Roger Stone's house
here on live television we're going to
cover it an hour before and an hour
after our coverage starts at noon
Eastern tomorrow
at our regular time here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
but also you have Stuart Rhodes going to
trial which they did their damnedest
they did their damnedest to stop
you don't think they understand the the
what is going to happen if Stewart
Rhodes
the evidence gets out in the public
which it will be because it'll be shown
in open court
that Americans aren't going to connect
the dots here the only challenge we have
is for people to open their [ __ ] ears
and their eyeballs that's it
stop paying attention to football for
two [ __ ] seconds and pay attention to
your democracy which delivers you those
great Monday nights Thursday nights
Saturdays and Sundays that you get to
enjoy with your football your democracy
delivers that dummies
you think you'd have the football teams
and the structure of football
you think you'd have broadcast
television you think you think you would
have internet just go go ask those women
in Iran who are challenging the regime
go ask them about internet
and a tyrannical fascist government
shutting down your [ __ ] internet
because you want to have a voice and
Liberty
and have a choice for your Liberty go
ask them
foreign
boy this next 40 days
is going to be some of the most
important days that we've had
in over a century in this country
in the 1930s and the 1940s
fascism was on the rise in the world
but the majority of this country
knew that it was [ __ ] dangerous
and knew that it meant
democracies would topple all over the
world
they knew that
they need a threat of fascism
but it wasn't here it wasn't trying to
take over our government it was just
trying to convince people and Gaslight
people that oh what's happening Germany
isn't a big deal the Nazis not so not so
great but not so bad either
that was the 1940s 1930s and 1940s here
under the America first party
don't thin veil it at all
but we're under threat
and we're about to see the threat that
we are under
they were going to use any means
necessary to take away your vote to take
away your way of life
that was their [ __ ] goal
the entire plan the entire scheme was to
make sure that Trump and his criminal
allies
would never see the inside of a prison
cell that's what they're terrified of
they're scared little
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] that's what they are
just like Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh
and the rest of them Tucker Carlson Sean
handy a bunch a goddamn [ __ ]
that can't that don't want to be held to
account for their nonsense and their
crimes
and they think they're above it all
and they blame leftists for being
elitist and entitled get the [ __ ] out of
here with that nonsense
no one more entitled than Trump his
children and his [ __ ] band of
miscreants
no one more entitled and anyone anyone
who [ __ ] supports him or votes for
him is in the same goddamn trees in this
category as far as I'm concerned
and we gotta start shaming these
[ __ ] into believing that
nonsense
that even if you if if you're just a
whiff just a [ __ ] whiff of support
for these buffoons is treasonous
traitors you're [ __ ] Traders every
last one of you are traitors to United
States Constitution and the American
people you're not a [ __ ] Patriot you
were a God damn Trader take the flag
down [ __ ]
because we find out as well there's
reporting that inside these boxes of
course that's it's not surprising
the [ __ ] that Tish James was looking for
the [ __ ] they subpoenaed
he was hiding that [ __ ] down at
Mar-A-Lago
and now that there's that there's
Federal Criminal
referrals from Dish James
about those [ __ ] documents
those documents are now criminal
evidence for not just this case but
other cases
and these people are going to continue
to support this idiot they think that
this road has some kind of great ending
well folks I'll tell you the ending that
they think it has
they're going to win this midterm
they're going to Crown Him King they're
going to take over our house they're
going to take over our Senate they're
going to get rid of Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris
they're going to take over the United
States and they're going to make it
their little fascist State and they're
going to do whatever the [ __ ] they want
and you're not going to say anything
different because votes don't count here
in America that's what they believe
that's what their plan is you can just
wait till you watch what Ryder Stone
says and Roger Stone is projecting what
Trump is telling him in his [ __ ] ear
believe it that's what is happening
and all these
nincompoop Nazis out there I'm talking
about the foot soldiers
that are still in support of this
[ __ ] idiot and this [ __ ] just vile
nonsense this treasonous [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what it is
it's treason
insurrection rioters
overthrow the game it's [ __ ] treason
I don't know how else to put it
what other [ __ ] word would you use
well where would you use
up and down the board no matter where
you go to no matter which one of these
[ __ ] were involved in planning on
overthrowing our vote and taking away
our democracy full stop 100 they were
all in on treason
the whole lot of them members of
Congress
[ __ ] state legislators
we're just lucky we have a backstop in
this country
we have a backstop of actual democracy
and Justice to some degree
their plan was the and it's obvious in
this video that was four months before
the election their plan was to take
Trump appointed judges and have them
crown him King and if that didn't work
then they would just they would just say
[ __ ] you I'm the president literally
that that is what he says I mean I'm
gonna show it to you
I'm gonna show it to you today of course
I gotta show you this [ __ ] tape
and we're gonna see it tomorrow for the
January 6 Select Committee
I gotta say something about the January
6th select committee and I'm not sure
exactly if it's Benny Thompson or Liz
Cheney here or Jamie Raskin
but I gotta say
they're absolute precision
Razer Precision to absolutely dissect
this entire [ __ ] event
before during the election
the night of the election after the
election the lead up to
the certification of votes after the
certification of votes
the lead up to the January 6th
insurrection
and then even after their Insurrection
failed
is absolutely 100 percent
killing the Republican Party
and the biggest reason why is because
they're still sycophanting for him did
you know did you know that the
Republicans put out some kind of plan no
you didn't no you don't you don't know
anything about it
do you know why because they're drowning
in treason
and we should [ __ ] put our foot on
the back of fascism's head and drown it
in democracy it's enough of the [ __ ]
enough of it
the nonsense the [ __ ] the absolute
[ __ ] lies and the way you can do that
is to pile mountains
mountains of votes on top of these
[ __ ]
can you imagine a world
in less than in less than two months
where the certifications are coming
through and Ron DeSantis is no longer
the governor of Florida Greg Abbott is
no longer the governor of Texas
they lose Senate races all the way down
to my state of Missouri because they're
a bunch of treasonous [ __ ]
and they want to take the rights away
from [ __ ] people
they done they done did it with women in
this country and they're coming for you
and they're coming for your [ __ ]
children
if we pile mountains of votes on these
sons of [ __ ] and show them that
you're not gonna take the [ __ ] Senate
not only you're not going to take the
Senate we're going to take more seats
than you thought
they will be doing really well if Ron
Johnson keeps his seat
as much treason as these [ __ ]
have committed
and been complacent with they know it
and then and then we gain seats in the
house it's up to you to gain these seats
yes I know I know they redistrict in
States and they're trying to cheat I get
it I get it I understand but you cannot
be scared of democracy
you have to lean into it they're trying
to scare you with democracy that's what
they're trying to do they convinced a
whole band of their supporters that
democracy doesn't even exist that way
when they snatch it away from them they
have no [ __ ] clue it was even there
but pro-democracy people understand
that that is not the [ __ ] case that
is a goddamn gaslighting lie
but it's up to you it literally is up to
you to engage in your democracy and yes
you have to use the power of your ballot
to drown fascism with democracy but you
have to engage
just look at what Beto's doing in Texas
engaging
with democracy and people are engaging
back
it's happening folks
now I don't want to get your hopes up
that you don't have to do anything
because that's nonsense too
this democracy [ __ ] is [ __ ] hard it's
difficult
it's not easy the easy thing is to let
an authoritarian tell you what the [ __ ]
to do
you think the women in Iran right now
are having an easy time
gaining back their [ __ ] Liberty their
choice
their religious choice
I don't think all these women who are
taking off their headdresses and burn
them actually want to walk around
without a head they just want the
[ __ ] Liberty
there's something about it there's
something about it
that empowers you
at Liberty that you know you know what
if I change my mind
and I decide I'm not this anymore and
I'm not that anymore I have the liberty
of being who I want to be loving who I
want to love
believing the things that I want to
believe by God you have the [ __ ]
Liberty to be stupid in this country
to believe the nonsense on Fox News you
have that Liberty
the greatest part about Liberty is you
have the Liberty to reject it and say it
loud and proud like I do every [ __ ]
day [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
that's Liberty that's what we strive for
and they're so goddamn deluded that they
don't even think they have Liberty
anymore and Liberty isn't what they
strive for
it's the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is what they think they
they're they're working towards that's
the freedom they want to oppress the
rights of other people and it's not that
[ __ ] many of them folks
it's not that [ __ ] many of them
yeah it feels like it
but you're talking less than 10 percent
but it's up to you to Mound mountains of
votes on top of them because there's
plenty other that are going to be
complacent in their place
so it's up to you it is up to you
to show them who we are
and show the world
you don't think it'll send a signal
to the rest of democracy around the
world when the United States tells Trump
and trumpism to go [ __ ] itself for the
second time
in two years
the first one was 2020. eight million
votes you really think 81 million people
voted for Joe Biden you are crazy
a shitload of people voted against
trumpism
Joe Biden might be a great president
but that ain't the reason why people
voted for him
I would have voted for a goddamn ham
sandwich
to be absolutely Frank with you
I would rather take my [ __ ] Chances
with a ham sandwich than with fascism
and I think the rest of America feels
the same goddamn way we just had to
activate and engage and let the American
people know that hey the threat is still
here it's still here these people who
want to get elected they want to Crown
Donald Trump King the same thing they
wanted in 2020 and we cannot allow them
to have any kind of power inside any
government that we possibly can help
State local
Federal all the way down to the God damn
dog catcher
you want a fascist dog catcher you want
would you want a trump supporter being
your dog catcher
as cruel and is hateful and bigoted are
they are think about how they would
treat an animal
if they treat human beings like they
treat human beings
it's your choice and what oh boy are we
gonna have plenty of information
tomorrow to make choices hell we got a
lot today that I'm going to
because you can't look away this
ignoring ignoring what these fascists
stay I get that all the time
I wish you'd stop promoting them I wish
you'd stop spreading their [ __ ]
I wish you'd wake up and open your
[ __ ] eyes and start showing it to
your goddamn family to your goddamn
friends
to the people you're around to get them
to engage
scare the ever loving Daylights out of
them you goddamn right you don't think
you don't think there's scary [ __ ] on
the other side of these [ __ ] idiots
getting Reigns of power again when you
watch this Roger Stone video that I'm
going to show you today
the absolute the absolute delusional the
delusional freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is on Full [ __ ]
display
on full [ __ ] display and it has
nothing to do with Liberty
it has everything to do with oppression
it has everything to do with taking your
[ __ ] rights away from you taking your
vote away from you taking your
Constitution taking your democracy
taking away your [ __ ] way of life and
they didn't give a [ __ ] because they
felt like they were entitled to it
because that's what they are they're
entitled little [ __ ]
their Cry Baby nincompoop Nazis
and it's treasonous [ __ ]
no matter how you frame it or how the
media wants oh both sad [ __ ] there
is no both sides to treason folks there
is no both sides
it's [ __ ] treason
the president of the United States the
administration officials
hell some members of Congress and
members of state legislators who took
Oaths to the Constitution
we're trying to overthrow the
Constitution and our government
and using any means necessary literally
he says any means necessary meaning
violence
no one in this country wants there to be
civil war or violence
and the people who do would get squashed
almost immediately we understand what it
will look like if there would be a Civil
War decent-minded people would
understand that the United States
military would absolutely
destroy anyone who wanted to go against
them
you really think your little stupid pea
shooters no matter how many you have is
going to be some kind of force against
the United States of America
and you want you're so such a patriot
that you want to fight them United
States military oh boy sounds like
you're really for veterans get the [ __ ]
out of here with that nonsense
but I have a feeling folks I have a
really strong feeling because I'm very
confident you know I'm very confident in
democracy because I believe that people
in this country understand what
democracy delivers
I believe that deep down in our core in
our American core
as ridiculous as we are
as is much entitled to delusion as we
want to be as much as we want to ignore
actually history
and what is real and what is fact deep
down inside of us we know what is most
important to this country
and it is Liberty
it is freedom it is the right
to those Constitutional Powers
that we have as a people
it's our government it's our way of life
it's us we the people
but it's up to you to use it
that power that constitutional power
that is granted to you the government
the people it's only up to you whether
you use it or not
and if you're worried about the voting
laws and them taking your rights away by
suppressing your vote
then you better [ __ ] vote
you better you better crawl over [ __ ]
broken glass and hot coals to get there
that's the way
that's what you have to do
I'm gonna show you a clip of Stacy
Abrams and she's going to explain to you
why Governors are way more important
than who the [ __ ] the president is who
the [ __ ] you remember Congress is
and who the [ __ ] your mayor is
God damn she Sharp
and The Way She lays it out
is absolutely beautiful
she's gonna make a great governor of the
state of Georgia
a great governor
even the people who hate her now will
love her then
I mean they'll pretend
they'll pretend like they hate her
but the thing she'll do for Georgia
for Georgians because she's not just
there for her constituents and it's the
same thing in Texas with Beto
when Texas finally makes the decision
that hey [ __ ] this goddamn Greg Abbott
guy [ __ ] this guy
he's not working for Texas
he's working for him and his donors
when they finally make that decision
even the people who [ __ ] hate battle
right now
even though they're gonna pretend like
they don't they're gonna like the [ __ ]
he does
that's what always happens
you know why because we don't run around
bragging and we should
we don't run around with rhetoric and we
should we don't run around attacking the
other side when we win and we should
they're at our front door trying to take
away our democracy this is not the
Republican party of Ronald Reagan folks
where they're just trying to seize up
power for their for their buddies their
Rich Buddies the one percent
Jesus Christ they're going to take it
away from the one percent too
you don't think the one percent enjoyed
democracy in this country
for them it's a thin veil plutocracy
you don't think they're going to take it
away from them [ __ ]
their goal is to take it away from
everybody just look at what they say
watch this Roger Stone video and tell me
I'm [ __ ] wrong everybody it's Tuesday
and you know what Tuesday means we have
Texas Paul here I believe we're going to
talk about a fugitive in Texas today
there seems to be a famous fugitive
something's going on in Texas down there
someone's running from the law I fought
the law and the law won I wonder if
they're gonna I wonder if
this is this is I can't even believe we
have to talk about this this is [ __ ]
ridiculous
that the head law enforcement officer
basically
in Texas
is a fugitive basically what in the hell
is going on
yeah the greatest part is he's oh he's
Greg Abbotts great buddy they're they're
buddies they're friends and if they're
not we shouldn't make them that way
that's right politicize the ever-loving
[ __ ] out of this
that's what we should do now Beto's not
but we can do it for him folks we can do
it for him that's the beautiful part
about rhetoric that's the beautiful part
about politization we don't have to
stand around and wait on the politicians
do it we can do it ourselves
yes I know it yeah oh what Tony that's
what the right wing does how do you
think they win you want them to win
which team are you playing on you
playing on team democracy or team
fascist
because if you're not fighting [ __ ]
against them you're fighting with them
when there's
10 people sitting at a table with one
Nazi
there's 11 people
that are Nazis at that table
that's what it is regardless of what end
you're sitting on regardless of of
rather you're talking to them or not or
engaging with them if there's 11 people
at a table and one of those people are
Nazis there's 11 Nazis sitting at that
table
so get with it folks get with it let's
get rid of Greg Abbott let's get rid of
Ron DeSantis because Rhonda Santos can
go [ __ ] himself folks this t-shirt is
flying off the shelves you guys like the
coffee mugs too go to
store.beat20michaels.com get the Rhonda
santoskin go [ __ ] himself also get some
doubt members while you're there
but the one that's really hot right now
at
store.dtonymichaels.com is the dark
Brandon exclusive Tony Michaels podcast
Design This thing is hot hot go get them
while they last store that the
tonymichaels.com get your doubt me merch
get your Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ]
himself also support pro-democracy
speech everywhere we're about to have
the king of pro-democracy speech Midas
Mighty favorite Texas Paul on don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
Tuesday you know what the hell that
means
Texas Paul Tuesday
owner of Gabe Sanchez is going to join
us that's all right we got Texas ball
here we'll get Gabe in here in here in a
second I want to ask Texas ball
map this fugitive down in Texas
apparently he's running around in this
pickup truck I want to see if it's a
white Bronco Texas Paul
good morning good morning how are you I
am wonderful I'm saying [ __ ] this Texas
Paul segment and you keep on that rant
that is the best damn rent I've heard in
decades I'm telling you brother I am
we'll cut that son of a [ __ ] up and
we'll make some clips out of it how's
that so do it do it I'm telling you that
was on the money on the money you nailed
it I mean point after point after Point
democracy we don't wait for Beto or
anybody else or Beto or Biden or anybody
else we are the democracy and it's time
we start talking some [ __ ] and telling
people the way it is it is I mean and
that's what I'm I'm with you man I tell
my people all the time
hey I may talk [ __ ] but you need to talk
[ __ ] because you're absolutely right if
there's one [ __ ] Nazi at that table
and 10 people sitting with them there's
11 goddamn Nazis at that table you damn
right you're damn right and you know I
know I know some people get you know as
shy about this because they got family
members and stuff well shame the [ __ ]
out of them it's time it's time these
Americans wake up and change their
[ __ ] minds and realize what they have
done what they've done the cat they have
let out of the bag and it's their
responsibility to put it back in but
it's our responsibility to tell them put
that [ __ ] back in the bag go crawl back
underneath the [ __ ] rock it's enough
of this nonsense when you have you
watched this Roger Stone video yeah not
yet I'm dying to see a delusion well I'm
gonna show it today I'm going to show it
today but the reason why I wanted you
um of course you're on every Tuesday but
I couldn't wait to talk to you about
this what in the actual [ __ ] is going on
with this fugitive down there in Texas
you know what I'm talking about
yeah Ken Paxton yeah oh is he the
sitting attorney general this is
ridiculous this is crazy yeah he's the
attorney general and uh see the problem
is it's it's deeper than just I mean
it's hilarious to laugh at it really is
but it's much deeper than that what you
got going on right now is they
overturned Roe v Wade and they found out
that they [ __ ] the bit
so everybody's expunging their their
bios you know overturning the road
they're pro-choice now right they're
pro-choice yeah all of a sudden yeah all
of a sudden they don't want to talk
about it well down here in Texas because
Republicans can't govern they made a
complete [ __ ] show of our loss we had
pre-love pre-roll laws on the book okay
so when Roe was over to overturned those
laws came back into effect well then
they wrote other laws that conflict with
those existing laws
they're identical enough that they don't
supersede the law
but they the the punishments are
different like uh the for supporting uh
uh funding somebody getting an abortion
in the state of Texas carries uh under
the new laws five to life under the Old
Law two to five
so you have groups that actually do this
for people because you know the big
problem is they talk about late term
abortions or after 16 weeks there's a
reason they do that because a lot of
poor people
have to get the funds together to be
able to afford an abortion they have to
get Transportation time away from jobs
this that and the other that takes times
well there are groups that actually help
them that that fund them so that they
can get this done
those groups have been suing Ken Paxton
saying look these laws are willy-nilly
their mishmash none of them are clear we
need guidance from you the head law
enforcement officer in the state what is
the law and Ken Paxton doesn't want to
talk about abortion at all right now I
mean he wants to say nothing about it
so
I mean they they had to subpoena him
he wouldn't do it willingly they had to
subpoena him seems like a pattern with
these [ __ ] traitors I mean yeah I'm
just saying there's nothing to hide in
your opinion and you believe in your
your opinion and you think that your
political stance is something you'd
stand behind you think [ __ ] get
in front of a microphone and say it yeah
well you'd think but he doesn't want to
stand in front of a microphone right now
and say yes if you help someone get an
abortion I'm going to prosecute you and
send you to jail possibly for life he
doesn't want to say that so he's been
hiding he's been hiding from every
camera in the world which is unlike Ken
walleye Paxton that guy usually loves
being in front of him yeah
and so he's hiding up in his house and
process server shows up at his house
knocks on the door talks to his wife
wife says well Ken's busy this that and
the other he's going to be tied up for a
long time he says no problem I'm a
process server I'll wait
all right and the guy walks he gets paid
he gets paid to hand him the papers
right so the guy walks back to his car
gets off their property walks back to
his car sits in his car I guess they
thought they waited long enough that the
guy left or something
Ken Paxton goes to walk out to his
pickup truck process over gets out of
his car walks up his driveway announces
who he is what he's got Ken Paxton turns
around and runs as fast as that fat ass
can run
all the way back into his house and
slams the door
so he stays in stays in the house for
about another hour right so the guy goes
back sits out in his car all of a sudden
an SUV pulls up
and then
Paxton's wife comes out and gets in
their pickup truck
opens the opens the the door behind her
it's a crew cab pickup truck opens the
door behind her well that's typical
behavior when you're gonna pull away
yeah and how run out runs Ken Paxton
from his garage as fast as he can run
and dives into his pickup truck slams
the door process server walks up to the
truck drops the papers and says you are
served
goes back and reports this whole
incident to the judge because you know
what people don't understand is just
because you don't accept the papers from
the process over doesn't mean they
haven't served you right if they've
notified you and even if even if they
can never catch you at your home
they can go back to the judge and say
hey I couldn't catch the guy at home and
tape it to your door and you're served
right so all of this was just stupidity
on Ken Paxton's part but it just shows
how terrified he knows this because he's
an attorney general for crying out loud
well he should know it and if he doesn't
know it he doesn't need to be an
attorney general of anything
yeah and that you could tell their whole
plan was to try to get away before the
guy could say you're served
you know and he did he walked right up
to the truck looked Ken Paxton right in
the eye told him you're served and
dropped the paperwork on the ground
and left and it was done done deal but I
mean the guy was just literally on the
run I mean he just anything he could do
to try to keep from getting served
because they do not want to talk about
Roe v Wade right now they would rather
get take a square kick in the nuts than
talk about Roe v Wade right hey I'm not
exactly against that I'm not exactly
against them you know I don't promote uh
physical violence but if they would
rather you know if we're playing Would
You Rather game you ever played that
game when you're a kid would you rather
if we're playing the Would You Rather
game I mean hell that seems like a good
would you rather would you rather talk
about your stance on abortion or take a
swift kick in the nuts I mean you know
it's just a game you play it's just a
game
do you think do you think though that
this has an effect on on the electorate
and the election in Texas just the
visual of this that he won't get served
well here's the thing right now Abbott
has been just blitzing the Airways with
this operation Lone Star
and the whole Roe v Wade thing because
they're expunging all of their websites
everything is actually gotten a little
quiet here in Texas
so Abbott has actually picked up a few
points in the polls but that's going
away because if you don't mind me
jumping off topic for a minute yeah go
ahead operation Lone Star as of today is
blowing up in Abbott's face
turns out see they've been fighting
requests for data on operation Lone Star
for from every journalist everywhere and
now it's starting to come out
what Abbott's been doing down here he
spent four billion dollars so far going
on five billion now with a B with a b b
billion dollars okay he activated the
National Guard sent them down to if
you've never been to South Texas that's
the Sonoran Desert okay sent them down
into the middle of a desert in the
middle of summer
five died
and and it it cost a [ __ ] ton of money
to do this okay then he took law
enforcement agents and shipped them from
one County
to counties on On the Border and turned
around and said man we're making
fentanyl arrests we're making we're
we're arresting people for for crossing
the border we're Prosecuting them and
this that and the other Well turns out
no they're not Joe Biden is you know
they try to say that the borders open
well one of the biggest [ __ ] we
Democrats have is Biden never repealed
title 42 from Trump right
so they are they are sending people that
back without trial because of the
coveted restrictions
left and right that's one of our biggest
complaints so no The Border's not open
second point that the border is not open
it comes out all these fentanyl requests
he's been uh arrests he's been claiming
have been happening at the border
crossings Tony who controls the border
crossing you mean the get the actual
Gates the actual Gates Right not not
over a fence or under a fence or through
a broken fence because if Trump made it
not not over the river not any of that
you're saying you're saying that they're
coming through the legal path the legal
gate that you're supposed to come
through you're saying that's where it's
coming through that's where they're
arresting them and you know I think yes
I think DHS is responsible
um and border security is responsible
the feds are responsible for those
they're making that's right none of this
has to do with the billions of dollars
that Abbott is spending the federal
government the the the
border patrol agents that are out there
are making the arrests for uh people
that are actually Crossing illegally
the most people that are coming across
are coming across through the through
the gates saying I want to Asylum from
the Nicholas Maduro uh
um
regime down in Venezuela that's just
brutally murderous
Communists which is even another it's
another damned dichotomy that we I can't
even understand why Republicans you
would think they would take advantage of
that but they're they clearly are more
hell-bent on on
dehumanizing brown people than they are
actually sticking to their what they
call their principles exactly exactly
and they're trying to say is all cartels
and this is the huge one this is the
this is the where Abbott gets the pie in
the face think about that number 4
billion going on 5 billion dollars
the fentanyl require arrests are being
done by federal agents
at the bridges at the portals oh at at
the ports where they're coming through
is where the federal agents are making
these arrests and Abbott's claiming them
as his own well the Chariot on the top
of the [ __ ] cake
85 percent of the fentanyl requests we
found out today the request I keep
saying requests 85 percent of the
fentanyl arrests we found out today
were American citizens
you mean you mean there's more you mean
the mules are actually Americans that
can cross in legal ports and legal
Crossings and that's the ones that are
going and getting the Fentanyl and
bringing it back are you telling me that
they're trying to work this fentanyl in
the trunk of a car behind the seat like
like they like they always have this is
again this is par for the course but hey
I want to show you a clip here I got a
clip here this is uh Fox news this
morning you know you said that your
attorney general Ken Paxton speaking of
the Border in this operation Lone Star
and then you rope in getting Paxton here
Ken Paxton did get in front of a camera
he's willing to appear on Fox News he's
not a willing to appear on his thing
else the funny part is
she doesn't really ask him she doesn't
really ask him about how he ran from the
law but let's let's watch a bit of this
glute let me see if I can get the volume
right
I'm gonna tell the audience why we're I
am adjusting the volume here we're going
to be changing our volume situation
hopefully this afternoon or tomorrow so
our volume problems are gonna start to
start to go away I have a feeling but
let's listen to this video we have
sovereignty as a nation
I suppose we should we do right but I
don't know anymore
Ken Paxton Attorney General of Texas
Mark brnovich Attorney General of
Arizona gentlemen you know what it takes
to get border patrol agents to talk with
you openly about this they want to serve
their government but you know who
they're most worried about the people of
this country A.G Paxton I'm going to
start with you is Texas doing the work
the governing on this issue that the
federal government is not doing
we're certainly trying I mean we have to
deal with natural disasters that but
with a natural disaster like a hurricane
it goes away this is a planned Disaster
by the Biden Administration that is
hurting my state that's hurting Mark's
State that's hurting the entire country
and as you as you talk to these
borderies Tyler 42 is still in place
I've been on the border I've been on
Horseback I've been in boats I've been
in helicopters he's also been in his
pickup trucker in and away from
subpoenas being served to him I'm not
going to play the rest of this garbage
again she goes on she never [ __ ] asks
him the real question everyone really
wants to know about their supposed top
law enforcement officer in the state who
won't be legally sir or try to be get
out of being legally served with the
subpoena because he won't lawfully
[ __ ] appear where he's supposed to
appear and they have to use the law to
get him to appear and you know and and
just more the same and Tony what he says
that this is a naturally this is a
man-made created design faster
how title 42 is still in place the only
thing the Biden Administration did
differently was they were not cruel with
the kids they make sure kids stay with
their families or if it's a kid that
gets caught that comes across alone or
or if it's kid that comes across with
can with somebody that's a a felon or or
that we arrest
that kid is reunited with their family
wait you're telling me you're telling
difference you're telling me there's
some Humanity there is that what you're
telling me yeah and that's the thing
they're saying this is a man-made crisis
like Biden did something different he's
doing exactly what Trump did that's the
Democrats biggest [ __ ] right is that
Biden is doing exactly what Trump did
title 42 is still in place
the only difference is they aren't being
cruel to kids and I guess that's what
Paxton is saying when it's a man-made
thing is that because we aren't throwing
kids in [ __ ] cages like animals that
this is suddenly you know an open border
which is all the other [ __ ] the other
difference too from what I understand
about the title 42 is the bind
Administration is working with the
Mexican Government on this title 42
whereas the Trump Administration was not
working with them they were just
dropping them off [ __ ] them just let
them do whatever the hell they want so
there's a little what did we get out of
that and what did we get out of that
Biden actually got Mexico to Pony up a
billion and a half dollars to help with
this problem so that we weren't just
dumping people right inhumanely back
across the border to nothing well
because it was causing a problem in
Mexico having all these folks having all
these folks being coyote by us back
across the border and just dumping them
and why what essentially became camps
right because they had no other place to
go which was causing problems on the
other side of the border so now that we
have an Administration that's willing to
work with the administration in Mexico
and try to help solve this Refugee
problem because that's really what we
have here we have we have migrants
fleeing from governments and we have
them trying to seek Asylum and refuge to
the majority of the extent that's why
that's why a lot of them are staying
here is because and they couldn't stay
here if they weren't legally seeking
Asylum that's the title 42 they're
sending the people back across that
aren't legally entitled to Refugee
status and and to seek legally seek
Asylum and let me put a bow on this Tony
that just tells you how [ __ ] awful
this is in the state of Texas we by law
have to have a balanced budget right
where the [ __ ] do you think four and a
half to five billion dollars is going to
come from well I'm sure I'm sure I'm
sure your energy trading your highways
will pay for it yourself
our roads our schools it's going to come
from our agricultural supports it's
going to come from our law enforcement
they're going to end up laying off law
enforcement over this
and he's talking about being the Law and
Order governor
you know I mean they are literally
pardon the expression but fist [ __ ]
our next budget so when Beto takes over
this is the first crisis that hits his
desk it's where the hell do I get five
billion dollars from
to cover
[ __ ] Abbott's re-election campaign
because that's all operation Lone Star
is he should be sued this should be a
class action lawsuit they are producing
nothing this is not a genuine law
enforcement operation the the guard has
no authority to arrest
them being there is just Visual and it
cost a shitload of money for that visual
um
exactly exactly we're literally
literally careening towards five billion
dollars with a B headline headline
headline headline headline
five billion dollars with a B to take
credit for what the [ __ ] Biden
Administration is doing right well you
know um I I would say the number one
question if I were in Texas and I would
say to lean into democracy and engage
the number one question I'd say for
people to ask is who do you want in
charge of fixing this five billion
dollar problem that the Republicans of
Greg Abbott have created do you want
Greg Abbott to help fix that problem or
do you want someone who's pragmatic who
gives a [ __ ] about Texas is gonna do it
it's not gonna be pretty but he's going
to do it try to do it the best way he
can is better that's your choice here
that's your choice you got the choice
whether you want the [ __ ] idiot who's
caused this problem who spent this Texas
money which shouldn't be spent on a
political stunt just like shipping
migrants all across the country when
they shouldn't be spending money on that
either they should be spending money on
trying to help these people seek Asylum
and refuge and get them get them
acclimated into our society and part of
our economy for crying out loud we need
the [ __ ] labor we need we need the
human means we need them here in this
country to keep our economy going and
another reason no can walleye Paxton
doesn't want to be put in front of a
camera is he's going to get asked the
question
are you using coveted relief funds
in this anti-abortion push and the
answer is yes
and that they're using it in operation
Lone Star did you know they emptied out
the an entire prison here in the state
of Texas took felons moved them to
for-profit prisons
and emptied out a prison down in Three
Rivers Texas it's called the Briscoe
unit and they're taking you know the
federal government
once they had arrest somebody
they hand them over to the state of
Texas but they pay the state of Texas
for that right for the detainment right
so he emptied out the Briscoe unit he is
putting
Asylum Seekers people waiting for
adjudication waiting to be sent back
and a federal high security I mean
pardon me a state high security prison
that's supposed to be housed housing the
worst of our felons
and he's telling nobody where he shipped
these people off to over a thousand of
our worst felons
I mean it sounds like human trafficking
it sounds on brand for these Republicans
to be quite honest with you
in did he cut him loose I mean I don't
know the the the for-profit prisons
won't tell us if they got them
you know because that looks bad that
that they're pumping people into the
for-profit prisons you know so they're
not going to talk to us about that you
know you can't get a [ __ ] straight
answer out of these people because
they're terrified because everything
they're doing looks like [ __ ] well it
looks criminal too I mean I know I know
there's a Sheriff
um San Antonio looking into Ron DeSantis
and his crimes that he's possibly
committed in Texas which is a weird
sentence to even say because Ron
DeSantis is the governor of Florida and
you think that [ __ ] would be
more worried about his State being
battered by a hurricane and had paid
attention to this hurricane you know if
I was Joe Biden you know what I'd do
because they're going to send federal
funds and ironde DeSantis is going to be
on his knees ready to do fellatio to
give to pass out federal checks to his
constituents which a governor should be
able to do
to help protect their state it doesn't
matter what [ __ ] State you're in or
who the governor is or who your
constituents vote for their goddamn
Americans are in America we should we
should stand behind people when there's
a national disaster like a flood or a
goddamn hurricane
but Biden should say Biden should say
I'm going to make sure to help Ron
DeSantis I'm gonna make sure to help
Rhonda Santos help his people in Florida
but I just hope I just hope that he
doesn't steal every single dollar that I
send him for those people in Florida
because he's got a history and if you
want to make sure that the governor of
Florida doesn't steal the money the
federal dollars that we're going to send
to help prop Florida up and give them a
head start here after this hurricane
because we know there's going to be
damage it's just it's just a thing
that's going to happen we're gonna lose
money they're gonna lose economy they're
gonna need some they're going to need
some relief what he should say is vote
in someone who won't steal the God damn
money
that's what he should say he should
politicize the ever loving [ __ ] out of
this point now I know Joe Biden's not
much of a politicizer but I'm going to I
am
I tell you I just went nuts I literally
just did a video on this man it'll be
coming out in a day or two I literally
just did a video on this it has footage
of a line of cars man you think they
were going to a Dolphins game you would
think they were going into a stadium man
this line is so freaking long of these
cars it's in Levee County Florida
they're going to a food bank right
they're going to a food bank and
DeSantis took and and the Republicans in
the legislature took 12 million dollars
sent a recruiter to Texas San Antonio
Texas
took people that were here legally
that were legally going through the
process of of getting Asylum
because they were escaping they were
Venezuelans escaping the Maduro murder
regime
and then put them on a plane lied to
them put them up in a hotel
made them sign releases that were
worthless because they were in half in
English and they knew they couldn't
speak English
then ship them up to Martha's Vineyard
as a big haha joke trying to trigger the
liberal trigger us liberals and and they
have no [ __ ] clue they didn't trigger
us we were so damn glad those people
weren't under Abbott's boot anymore
they're out there getting help with
their cases they're up there being you
know getting the hand up that they
should be you know as as My Brother's
Keeper they should be be being they
should be being treated but he took that
money
from Florida who's got people lined up
in food banks to send legal people to
[ __ ] Martha's Vineyard you would
think you would think Floridians would
have the wherewithal to uh and I think
they do I think that's the biggest fraud
that has been wrought on our country is
somehow this is a half half thing this
is not a half half thing
when when Joe Biden came out and called
Maga Republicans fascist he did not tell
half of the country they were fascist
because half the country doesn't buy
this Maga [ __ ] they just don't that
is such a [ __ ] fraud they don't buy
that nonsense that is such [ __ ]
they just don't I can't [ __ ] I can't
tell you how much I think that's a bunch
of [ __ ] and I think if we just if we
all band together and we take our
government back and we do what we're
supposed to do which is democracy
and anyone who can vote votes check your
registration get anybody you can
register to vote make sure they check
the registration engage in your
democracy let them know what's at stake
and I believe it's an easy goddamn
decision just like in Texas the question
do you want Greg Abbott to try to fix
the budget problem that he created is
that who you want to fix it or do you
want someone who's got a half a [ __ ]
brain who's willing to sit down and tell
the honest truth to Texans and give it
to him straight that hey the last guy
[ __ ] this up and works gonna cost us
money but we gotta do it there ain't
nothing to do but the Constitution it's
the law but we're going to try our damn
this we're going to try our best and I'm
going to try to create a plan to get us
out of it instead of burying Us in
another [ __ ] hole like Greg Abbott
would do so that's the question you
gotta have folks whether you're in Texas
or all around the country
Hey sir you gonna let these buffoons who
are spending our [ __ ] money on
[ __ ] political stunts and taking it
away from you that's the question you
gonna let them be in power you're gonna
let them keep doing it
speak the question we gotta ask speak it
brother speak it
so that I think is the the thing that um
we need to get through the skulls of
people in the next 40 days now we got a
hearing tomorrow that's going to help uh
shed some light on some things
um that's going on in our country
um what what do you make because you're
gonna join us tomorrow Texas Paul as you
have uh for the coverage of the January
6th select hearing but we got day nine
coming up it's been a while since we've
had one of these hearings it's it's the
start of season two of treason Hunters
as I called it this morning
um what do you make of this hearing what
do you expect do you think this is going
to move the needle or do you think it's
been too long since the last one or do
you think that's by Design
no no I I I think part of it was letting
Benny Thompson get over covet I think
part of it was the collection of
evidence that that this just Tony this
ballooned I mean everything that they
got into everybody they talked to kept
saying oh by the way did you know this
happened also and they're like what what
get the notebook start writing things
down and then well we need to subpoena
this and we need to I mean it just
ballooned and and and I think that's
been the delay between that and that
they've been cooperating with the doj on
everything that's happened so far
and mark my words what's coming down the
pike I have heard this I haven't
confirmed it what's coming down the pike
is you remember that video of trump
loading boxes
into his private jet yeah sure I
remember that that was two days after he
was notified
that the government wanted that back
right that was two days and that jet was
going to Bedminster you watch you watch
they are gonna raid every damn property
he has
and I don't I you know he better have a
lot of [ __ ] ketchup that's all I've
got to say well he's better half
stalking it well I'll tell you I'll tell
you the other the other um word this
morning is there's some reporting
showing that it's possible Department of
Justice is signaling to the Attorney
General of New York that hey those
documents that you wanted for your civil
case that you subpoenaed they're they're
in these [ __ ] dirt they were in his
desk drawer hidden in in melania's
closet or wherever the hell he had them
in the pool house wherever he had him
look it is not surprising to me that
this guy is going to continue to commit
crime this is not surprising the only
thing that will surprise me is if he
actually if he was smart enough to evade
this that was what will surprise me Tony
Tony
what is so bad about those documents
being in those boxes
down in Mar-A-Lago is that Trump sat
under oath and said
I don't know [ __ ] about this this is the
company that runs it I don't know the
stuff you're looking for talk to Alan
weiselberg this is the company I don't
know [ __ ] about it so you're saying you
should have put the food
you lied under oath because you knew you
took those specific documents tomorrow
[ __ ] Lago well because he thought he
could take it across the state line
there's no way they would find it that's
why he's pissed off that's why he keeps
saying they're my it's my [ __ ] and ain't
got nothing to do with the government
because it's got to do with other crime
in other states he always tells on
himself he always does it that's why I
believe the goddamn top secret uh the
classified information the human
intelligence that he that he stole from
us from our government has his goddamn
name on it it is intelligence that our
intelligence and then our intelligence
agencies has collected on him
and that's why he keeps saying it's his
because it's got his stupid [ __ ] name
on it and I keep comparing him to Al
Capone yes Al Capone was a vicious
murderer he ran numbers rackets he ran
extortion rackets he you know broke the
Volstead Act and sold booze and every
other damn thing in the world they could
not nail him down for because everybody
was terrified of him they got him on tax
evasion they got him on the cover up
that's what he went to sing sing for and
the same thing will happen to Trump
trump just lied under oath
that he did not know a damn thing about
these documents and they were in his
goddamn desk drawer and in his safe he
he moved them to another state
he took them out of the companies he
took them out of the companies
uh storage and moved them to Mar-A-Lago
he lied under oath Tony he lied under
oath period there's no other way about
it no other way around it what's he
going to say uh um I I guess Eric did
that I mean who do you think he's going
to try to throw under the bus for that
nobody man he's done he's [ __ ] done
well that's why today's that's why it's
today's thumbnail
um presents that in the most obvious way
I can I can show he's [ __ ] he's
absolutely [ __ ] here he knows he's
[ __ ] that's why he's been freaking out
that's why he's been freaking out about
the FBI breaking into mar-a-longo and he
really thought that under under the
guise of being the former president and
and and using fear and stoking fear and
violence in the country and he had
Secret Service there as what he thought
would protect him not just privately not
just publicly but legally from law
enforcement coming in and seizing this
[ __ ] that's why he had it down there
it's because they're protecting that
house because he's there and and
unbeknownst to them I bet these federal
agencies Secret Service I bet they've
been wearing wires I bet they've been
informing because there they have an
oath and I don't give a [ __ ] if their
oath is to protect them their oath is to
protect our constitution as well
and let me leave you with a happy
thought yeah
if he gets convicted if mayor Garland
gets him he goes to Club Fit right
but when he lied under oath even though
it's a civil suit up in New York
that sends his ass to a place like
Rikers oh baby well I I will tell you
you can enjoy that state time you stupid
fat orange mango Mussolini [ __ ]
enjoy your state time well I I think
he's gonna get uh state and federal time
um here for a lot of different things
because he's committed a lot of crime
he's really and he he is committed to
keep climbing he's not gonna stop I mean
this is this is a habit he can't break
apparently and uh Texas Paul as always I
always appreciate you joining us on
Tuesday and tomorrow we'll have you with
the coverage uh on Midas Touch network
of the January 6 day 9 hearing I'm super
excited to see this Roger Stone stuff uh
stick around in the green room if you
want to watch this video Roger Stone I'm
going to show a couple Clips here of
Roger Stone absolutely losing his ever
loving mind and admitting right out in
the open you got God yeah did you did
you order a code red you goddamn right I
did that's exactly it is the code red
moment of Roger Stone uh it is a freak
out moment and it's it's months before
the election which is even more telling
that this was all premeditated they knew
he was gonna lose and they planned on
stealing it if he did lose that was the
plan the entire [ __ ] time and you'll
see that in this clip and tomorrow I
can't wait for you to join us on the
January 6 um select hearing but give us
one last Shameless plug because I know
you got a couple shows going over on
your YouTube channel so give us a
Shameless plug here
all right uh Wednesday night man we're
starting at 8 central we are it's me and
Tennessee Brando uh talking about
current events it's a great show it's
just 30 minutes it's short it's quick
it's fast it's sweet we hit it hard we
bring we're bringing in a great guest uh
a lot of people know her to Care Bear
she's got straight up documents on on
them trying to you know they're
constantly trying to rewrite fiction uh
about what happened in the past and
they're trying to reinvent Trump's
economy she's nailing them to the wall
with that she's she's good to go on that
and then Sunday there's always Sunday uh
coffee with Texas Paul where I talk
about kind of a wrap-up of the Week
events and what's been happening lately
I sure appreciate you all available on
my uh my YouTube channel can be found
through my link tree it's it's linked
tr.e slash Texas Paul
well thank you Texas Paul thanks for
joining us I look forward to tomorrow
when you join us for the coverage of the
January 6th select hearing and uh
everyone go follow Texas Paul's YouTube
channel and catch his Wednesday show and
the Sunday show and Tony I always got to
say it man I am here uh you know I am
here because I love being here I love
being with somebody which has as much
damn passion as I do about this you are
the best podcast
available right now
you are setting the bar you are raising
the standards and damn it man I it's a
pleasure to be here every damn time you
and Gabe kill it just kill it every week
and it's it's my pleasure to be here
well yeah it's a good pleasure to have
us it's your our pleasure to have you is
what I mean
not just on Tuesdays anytime you need to
you can come on this show not just
Tuesdays of course you're welcome on
Tuesday
yeah I will take you up on it I'm going
to mute out I want to see this video
this that I haven't had a chance to see
it yet that's great everyone stick
around we're gonna come back uh we
should have Gabe Sanchez with us on the
other side of the break we're gonna
watch this Roger Stone video Texas Paul
thanks for joining us as always on
Tuesdays everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back back to the show
Texas fall Tuesday
hails to the yeah I want to welcome all
the new audience members here to the
Tony Michaels podcast if you're new if
you're watching this I don't care where
you are whether you're on YouTube the
twitch the Tweety tweets the trendy
Trends over on the books of face or if
you're at Tony Michaels dot live it does
not matter to me I'm glad that you're
here and I'm glad that you're with us
speaking of Tony Michaels dot live don't
forget to support Independent Media this
is super important just as Paul said
just like you should go over to Texas
Paul's YouTube channel as soon as this
is over
and go hit the Subscribe button smash
that button and watch him every single
Wednesday and Sunday catch that show
either live or after the fact you have
to support Independent Media it is
vitally important
and the reason why is because we can no
longer rely on the profit driven media
out there the mainstream
they think they still have to placate to
these fascists to keep their profit
motive going
I don't believe that is the case I
believe that you the pro-democracy
people want to support
pro-democracy speech everywhere
and every facet
and again if you can give support to
Independent Media
by by consuming Independent Media
hitting the Subscribe button sharing it
with your families your friends
but you can also do that by giving to
independent meaning if you'd like to
support the Tony Michaels podcast we
appreciate that it keeps us going here
it keeps me yelling and screaming into
this microphone it's what gives me the
ability to bring Texas Paul here and
talk some sense into people in Texas
so do me a favor go over to
tonymichaels.live if you can give us a
tip it's a one-time tip or you can do a
monthly tip either way it's much
appreciated
now you don't have to just get money
just share that link Tony Michaels dot
live with your family your friends
email it hell you can fax it to people I
don't care what kind of Technology
you're using but just go to
tonymichaels.live support Independent
Media there you can also find our merch
store just go to that sandwich icon up
top you can get some doubt me merch or
go to store.thetonymichaels.com
for your doubt me merch or your Ron
DeSantis can go [ __ ] himself merch which
is flying off the shelves you guys love
this design
love this design on coffee mugs hoodies
shirts I think it's one of the best
designs we got but the exclusive dark
brand of design we got boy holy moly
everyone loves this thing so don't
forget to go check out the exclusive
Tony Michaels podcast dark Brandon
design on a t-shirt a hoodie coffee mug
or a sticker you know you do to really
piss off your Trump your Trump family is
get a Tark Brandon sticker and stick
that [ __ ] anywhere you can help go buy
four or five of those dark Brandon
stickers
and stick them all over your Trump pump
and your uncle's honest on his in his
bathroom on the mirror help put it on
his pickup truck anywhere you can I know
I know Gabe Sanchez loves these these
dark brand and these these stickers that
we got have you have you put them on the
I slap him on my back of my Ford F-150
with those truck nuts you know
exactly is that the kind of truck that
uh that that fugitive Ken Paxton drives
is a 45 50. I think so uh I would assume
I would assume
uh that he that he would probably he
would probably drive one of those trucks
with like some dangling metal nuts you
know yeah I mean
it's one that my mom mommy should say
you're as uh she whenever like I
wouldn't do chores or something she'd be
like you're as useless as tits on a bull
and that is how I look at these people
uh I only bring it up because I remember
these balls in the back of a truck
because they're they're pointless
they're useless they don't do [ __ ] right
and that's when I look at the Republican
Party they're completely
they're nuts they're crazy right they
are they are the truck nuts of our
country yeah like in human form they're
the truck nuts in human form is that
what you're saying just just just trying
to you know overcompensate for things
that they what's that just trying to
what what gate what are they trying to
oh okay you're talking about nuts you're
talking about yeah you know yeah
perverted Republicans they're yeah I was
talking about this yesterday with
someone they are absolutely infatuated
absolutely infatuated with with
genitalia and children sexual what is
with these people why are they so
focused when we got other [ __ ] to deal
with I just don't understand it's it's
because you know they they have to
appear you know they have to give the
appearance that they're doing their job
and if they can cause any sort of fake
outrage or a problem that they have to
solve then it shows that they're doing
their job right right they can go to
their constituents and say look at this
[ __ ] mess over here in DC that I
created but I am going to fix right well
sort of well we won't get it back where
it was well it's like hey I propose this
bill that's batshit crazy but I propose
this bill and Democrats denied it I'm
not the problem they're the problem it's
like maybe because that bill didn't do
[ __ ] or even took away more rights from
U.S constituents but that's the thing
that they do they they try to create uh
a themselves be relevant and important
by causing problems and then trying or
looking like they're fixing them and
then placing the blame on Democrats
right Oh you mean like you mean like an
election where they try to actually
steal and overthrow an election and a
government and then they go and they
they're the ones tampering with voting
machines they're the ones trying to
subvert an election they're the one
trying to overturn a state certification
sounds really familiar like that you
mean like that and it's all premeditated
because there is evidence now and
tomorrow we're gonna watch it in the
select yeah I've got a video I want to
show you in the [ __ ] let's round up so
let's do this let's go round up the
Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends the
[ __ ] list Roundup coming at you let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the show to the
shitless Roundup Gabe do you got your
camera done over there is that is he
good
yeah you're not your microphone see
[Music]
the reason it was slow is because I was
rendering uh the what was that I was
exporting oh I see so like as it's going
through it's it's like yeah we're gonna
use like a few flashes and yeah there's
something weird going I'm keeping you on
your toes that way I thought it was
maybe the Deep State over there no no
I'm getting in on this yeah yeah no it's
the it's the well I mean I guess we
could play it today if you want to but
it's the what was that about yeah it's
the one with that what
was that that's about uh
J.R Majewski Majewski well hey that's he
that's um that's I'd like to see that
let's do that load that in thing into uh
uh YouTube as a private link and send me
the uh the link and then I'll I'll play
it here in a minute but the first thing
I want to get to here
oh boy the thing that everyone's gonna
be talking about for the next several
days is this dumb [ __ ]
Roger Stone stodgerone as we've referred
to him
um it would appear that they did get a
hold of that uh
that documentary footage I think that is
what happened I think that is what
happened it sounds like that is going to
be a um a very
big part of the hearing tomorrow that we
will be covering on the Midas touch
Network it'll be at a regular time so
we'll be airing here yeah on this
channel as well the same time uh noon
Eastern uh 11 Central 9 Pacific that's
when our coverage will start some people
get confused they're like wait the
hearing starts at one Eastern I'm like
yeah but we're an hour before baby we
give you that commentary before let you
know what the hell is coming or try to
because we don't always know exactly
what the hell these earrings are gonna
bring yeah um but this Ryder's Stone I'm
gonna have to make sure I don't have a
hot mic on when the when the evidence
drops um I think there I was on a hot
mic moment once during these hearings it
was it was a Roger Stone moment it was a
Roger Stone moment this is what happened
they presented some evidence I think it
was a photo or a video right and you're
like oh baby and what I had to do was
luckily I was right there I had my
finger on the mouse right with the mute
and I muted you but it was a funny
because it was just like there was a
pause and it was ooh baby and then boom
and right back into the presentation so
pull the new baby and you can actually
go if you find that if you find that I
tell you what if you find that I will I
will give you if the first one who finds
that out there and tweets that at me or
some [ __ ] I don't know how you move your
time stamp on the link or some [ __ ] I'll
figure out something I'll figure out
something to send you a [ __ ] sticker
or something like that just uh just go
go find that moment where I'm like
you got eight videos to go through
you'll find it I feel like it's like the
first half of them but I don't know for
certain right and if you want if you
want to know where the video is at you
just go to Midas Touch YouTube channel
they're at a playlist in the very top
yeah but I go
baby
and that's the because I was I was
excited like they're gonna dig into this
because there's gonna be some Ooh Baby
moments tomorrow I have a feeling and
hopefully I'll I'll try to add my text
messages
and we've got you know they're probably
gonna dig into more of what
uh was discussed during the 60 Minutes
segment and they're probably gonna you
know make connections you're you're
talking about you're talking about the
monster that we talked about yesterday
right the graph of connections between
different the six groups the planning
medicating exactly so I wouldn't be
surprised if tomorrow because I don't
know what what the rest of these
hearings hold for in terms of when they
are or what the format will be but right
I'm almost positive
that I feel like it's going to be the
text messages it's going to be we
recovered these from the Secret Service
despite them saying that they're
completely gone and it reveals that
these people are in communication they
knew what was happening this story's
corroborated like Cassidy Hutchinson you
know all of these things are going to be
out there you know all of the and the
other the other thing too is like the
Secret Service agents have now private
counsel if there was anything that they
had to hide you know obviously that's
why they're getting private counsel but
it's like if there's nothing to hide
then there's no reason to get any sort
of uh lawyer up right well and because
also the the text messages that the
Secret Service said no we erase the I
mean they're lost right did I say erased
I meant lunch I meant they actually yeah
and they're like they're like what days
are you looking for oh the fifth and the
sixth yeah those are gone yeah those are
gone yeah it's we've urged them sure for
some reason for whatever reason those
days when when there was treason being
committed those are gone well they found
them they apparently found the majority
of them so it seems like there's going
to be a lot of Secret Service that's
also [ __ ] here right yeah and I don't
know what methods they went about going
to get them or what happened but I will
say uh I'm interested to see what the
text messages say right well we actually
we actually surmised this when this
story broke that they were looking for
these text messages and they had been
mysteriously deleted yeah they actually
said on the show that's not exactly like
you would have to scrub
like there is there is certain ways you
would have to absolutely get rid of
these things because it's not just on
the one device right I mean that data
lives in a lot of different places when
you send a text message right because
and I think a lot of people don't
understand how significant it is that
like riggleman
um in his 60 Minutes interview laid out
like look at the [ __ ] communication
points here and look at the graph of
organization that they actually have and
I don't think people really understand
because it is a mass of data and it's a
lot of stuff to sift through but I don't
think people understand how much time
the Department of Justice has to
actually take down the Top members of
this organization because really when
you look at that the monster is as
Denver riggleman the former uh uh
National Security veteran uh lays out
but he's also a former Republican
Congressman which is even worse for
these Republicans to be quite honest
with you because it's a it's a Democrat
run command any no honest honestly I I
probably if I sat down with Denver
riggleman I would I would imagine I
could talk to the guy for eight to
twelve hours I would bet we agree on
maybe three things maybe and I'm talking
about politics we could probably agree
on like food and you know some other
social stuff right you know like oh yeah
beer good like those sorts of things
like no you know you would probably
agree that and you and him would agree
that Taco Bell isn't tacos like there's
a lot of things like you say it's not
said salsa like there it's Taco Tuesday
so we gotta talk about tacos at some
point on this episode yeah right right
but but the point I'm trying to make is
that we wouldn't agree with Denver
riggleman on [ __ ] anything right
here he is some liberal D's Sorrows deep
State Democrat this is all ridiculous
stuff I mean it's George Soros is the
one that's finding his uh his private
firm so you know it's clear that oh is
that is that the word well I mean that's
the word on probably some something I'm
sure well I mean this isn't that isn't
hard to surmise so I'm sure they've
already they've already put that out and
to remind folks like the way that text
messages work when they go from let's
say my phone to Tony's phone is that
we've got local copies that are on our
phones if we so your phone and my phone
yeah yeah I've got I have a version you
have a version assuming that the texts
were sent through uh if I backup my
phone in the iCloud or somewhere else
those that backup is there a copy as a
copy now if I delete those messages from
my phone let's say and from the cloud
there's only a certain amount of time
that these providers these these cell
phone providers will actually hold on to
those text messages I think Verizon's
the longest with like a week or
something like that and the other one so
you're saying so what you're saying is
if we were if we were trying to commit a
coup let's just you know just as a
hypothetical I mean no one would
actually try to do that yeah but but me
and you were texting back and forth how
we were going to overthrow the
government and convince the vice
president to take up these fake State
electors or we're going to hang him just
just a theory just you know yeah just
kind of a great little story that we've
got going here
but if we text each other back and forth
what you're saying is if I'm on variety
let's say I'm on a d and you're on
Verizon Verizon might hold yours for a
longer time than they actually hold my
data is that what you're saying yeah so
well like what's uh well it's actually
the on their server so if you're getting
your phone your your account yes it is
whatever is being served up from that
that uh provider and so some of them
hold it for longer some of them I think
maybe some of them might not even hold
it that for like a day three days five
days but I think like seven days is the
longest with for our nine days with
Verizon but it's all automatically
deleted yeah yeah they Purge I mean like
that's terabytes of data you have to
think there are so many billions of
people in the world and they're storing
those I mean while they're little bits
of data you know now you have to think
of how many messages you send on a daily
basis uh from you know you to your wife
you to your kids you to me to anyone
else
you have to think of like the amount of
data I mean like probably more than you
know pentabytes or whatever like that's
how much data probably is out there on
text messages alone and so you'd have to
think as a as a cell phone provider
you're like I don't want to host that
stuff and if I do right because it costs
money to hold that date right right so
what I want to do is I want to hold it
for a certain amount and I want to purge
it and then I'm going to go through I'm
just going to cycle through
um and they would set up the AI to do
this efficiently yeah yeah and again
like this is you know I see someone here
that says no text no phone calls record
I don't know what they're talking about
but
it's it again one of those things where
it's a range of like a day to seven or
so days that a provider could hold it so
if you didn't back it up and wiped your
phone
and
you probably don't have the text message
I mean there are records of like who you
texted but not the content inside now
this brings up a good a good point
because these providers have these texts
and these these this data would there be
a reason why law enforcement whether it
be federal or anyone else or congress
um would subpoena and tell these cell
phone companies hey we we want to make
sure we have this data so you need to
make sure that it doesn't automatically
get wiped we want to make sure we can
access that data is that a thing that
happens is that a thing that you know to
say that don't delete it well I mean
that that that these companies Verizon
ATT cell phone providers could go in and
say oh okay so you're wanting you're
wanting this data so we'll make sure
that that data doesn't get erased
um do you think there's the potential
that if you if you get them early on
before it's wiped to say hey we've got a
subpoena and we want this stuff like
right now I mean again you know you have
to remember this stuff was request did
for the Secret Service or from the
Secret Service to get those text
messages and then they delayed it was
the whatever the Watchdog group was they
said hey we need these text messages to
see what happened during these days and
then it was like 11 12 days later and
they're like oops we don't have it right
but I mean what if what if what if
um a law enforcement agency whoever it
was yeah and I'm just you know I'm just
tossing out Stones here not Roger Stone
but Stone okay okay let's say let's say
that the um the cell phone providers
were told by the law enforcement ages
hey within this range within Washington
DC because this is where it was
happening physically because they know
it was physically happening in this area
and they say you know we want to make
sure we obtain this data in the entirety
of this area because the other that the
cell phone providers would probably have
to provide that the other thing that I
want to ask you because I think this is
significant and again this is all just
us back and forth about text messages
and data and what what you know about
data being backed up because what I
understand is when you're in a real big
commercial style building like a stone
building or metal but kind of like the
the United States capital uh the service
the service isn't very good in a
building like that from an outside Tower
is that right
uh I mean generally speaking Yeah the
thicker the walls the concrete you know
like if you were to go down and lower
floors and stuff like that you're going
to have a harder time getting a signal
that I mean the you have to also
remember that the people who enter the
capital those devices like the capital
the the capital police and those who
have actually you know secure the
capital
um they this isn't their first rodeo so
basically when you enter a building a
like a capital like the capital that was
stormed let's say you have a Verizon
let's say you have a Verizon phone right
an iPhone and it's I will say this every
device that entered that [ __ ]
building is a tracking device that they
now know great this thing tried to Ping
the tower we know who it was or what
number it was and they could say great
now we have the ability to track you
wherever you go after that assuming you
keep the same phone right you've now put
basically a marker on that phone to say
this thing was here during this when
window of time right if it comes to the
messages now what you'd have to say is
if you caught it in the window before
they Purge they could say great it was a
penis we can we can get it the only
other group that I would know that would
be able to do this to actually access
messages in some level way way deeper
than
um you know the doj would be like the
NSA like those are the ones like so what
you're saying is there's probably a
government agency out there that is
collecting this data and storing this
data regardless of Verizon 18t the
Secret Service someone else deletes this
information that's is that what you're
saying I mean
somewhere in a big huge building in
Denver Colorado or something it could be
stored somewhere uh you know and if a
certain agency was given a heads up or a
tip to say hey we need something during
this period I don't know
just one because you have to remember
that I mean if anyone remembers Snowden
or when like prism was revealed you know
like speaking of Snowden you know Russia
I think he just got his citizenship or
whatever oh did he really oh well that's
that's great as the Russian regime is
about to be top right I'm sure he's
really excited about that uh do you
think he's fleeing to Georgia by now I
don't know I'm just no I think he's fine
yeah Putin grants Russian citizenship to
U.S Wilson but what I will say is that
what what happened uh I forget how many
ever a few years ago or a handful of
years ago when this was revealed that
the NSA was tracking you through all
these things right they're like hey we
need a back door to this we need a back
door to that we need ways to track this
and that
they're the only group outside of uh
some other you know cyber security
agency that would have access or the
capabilities to get that stuff because
remember they are tracking conversations
that we have on a daily basis looking
for keywords or phrases or certain
contacts in connection to say ugh red
flag we got to look into this person or
red flag we got to look into this group
or whatever right that would be the only
group that I could uh identify that
would have access to messages that
potentially
were maliciously or
um
uh uh deleted on purpose right like you
say oh what happened on the fifth and
the sixth they were deleted
intentionally then the NSA says well we
might have those floating around right
right right well because the idea this
idea that because as everyone knows when
you say don't post something on the
Internet that you don't want it to be
there it's there it's never gonna be
whatever you delete in whatever way like
even if you could Purge it from a basic
like consumer level somebody has access
or can find it I guarantee you the same
goes for a text message the same goes
for a phone call if you're going to
commit High crimes of treason and
Insurrection to overthrow our
constitution yeah and you're hell-bent
on it any means necessary is we're going
to watch Dodger Rhone say here in a
second
because it it's not it's not surprising
it's a little shocking to hear it the
way he says it four months before the
election happens because it really does
go at a premeditation here but the
the thought that these [ __ ]
nincompoop Nazis really really believed
that they could just like delete the
text messages off their cell phone and
that it was not gonna appear anywhere
else that they could absolutely scrub
every single place where this data
existed was really [ __ ] bone-headed
yeah and and I mean it was really
bone-headed if you try to make certain
Communications within the building after
your phone was identified because
remember again because they have pinging
towers and not not just outside but
inside the building yeah correct like
this is this is something that's like
again as soon as you as soon as you are
in proximity of that building right they
need to assess uh for if something
happens then you assess like whatever
the threat level is so if you come in
there something happens they need a
record of every person that was in there
and the best way to do that is to track
you know whatever your phone is right
and so by doing that then they say great
we have the number we have this is the
carrier we potentially have if there are
messages that were captured I don't know
right that could be a thing but that is
one of those things where you look at it
and you're like every every like our
phones are already tracking devices but
once you entered that building you
became a a person of interest that they
were like great we know exactly which
device to track it's now when [ __ ]
Virginia and it's uh or like oh that
phone pinged another phone across the
Potomac or whatever it was right like
that is well the other thing too is
right after January 6 when we had uh
some of these committee hearings in the
Senate and the house you had these
Republican Senators and Republican
congressmen I remember Josh Hawley
specifically was like okay explain how
let's just hypothetically say that my
phone was in the cat can you explain to
me how that works so we can make sure
the only reason he was asking that is
because he was [ __ ] he's like oh [ __ ]
like right their phones are in the
capital every day I was in the capital I
ran my ass away but before I ran and I
was texting someone and I don't want
people to know what I was texting right
so uh is this stuff able to be tracked
right right even on my burner phone or
like whatever it is and I remember uh
the FBI director not confirming or
denying but basically saying yeah if
your phone is in the capital and you
were you were you were actually
exchanging data on it we know we [ __ ]
know right we [ __ ] know dummies yeah
because the the longer the short of it
is of course the Department of Justice
the FBI the Secret Service
um other law enforcement to Capitol
Police made sure that that data was
captured they they understand how
important that data was going to be
right and that's what they did they
captured that data now regardless of
where they tried to scrub it from
there's copies [ __ ] everywhere
because I'm sure there's not just copies
on each server Tower but when your phone
pings especially if it's set up to roam
your phone is pinging not just off your
your carrier's Towers it is pinging off
other carriers Towers if it can't ping
off its own right so there's data that
lives everywhere everywhere now some of
it is automatically scrubbed and some of
it lives rather probably deep down dark
in some [ __ ] deep archive that takes
you know month Stacks or recover and
look through but it exists guarantee
that when you walk anywhere if you're on
camera anywhere your cell phone's being
pinged anywhere that data is being
[ __ ] stored somewhere count on it
[ __ ] count on it and to have these
nincompoop Nazis like this dumb [ __ ]
just to basically not only be in
Washington DC with his cell phone are
his two or three cell phones I'm sure he
had to have a couple burners I'm sure
that day yeah but here's the thing this
guy is on camera four months before the
election this is this is before the
election even happens he's on camera
saying this [ __ ] now listen to how he
lays out and he's premeditating what he
wants to have happen if Donald Trump
loses because it really feels like in
this little
this rager that he has and I'm not sure
what he's hopped up on here but and I'm
surprised like I said earlier that this
guy even has teeth as much as he grinds
them down to Nubs yeah as he's Jack
jawing but when when when he says what
he says about how they're gonna plan on
making sure even if Donald Trump doesn't
get
um elected how they're gonna steal the
vote
um this is again it's not surprising but
it's a little shocking to hear this four
months before the election in a private
room with
the Nixon picture it's really I mean
you asked what the drug was that he's on
I honestly think he got himself a hold
of Nixon's ashes like oh really I don't
know what stadium that's what he's
snorting I don't know I'm just saying
like he kind of you know puts it into a
pill-like form and then maybe you know
yeah I don't know oh my God
oh I can only imagine the guy [ __ ]
loves Nixon he's got a Nixon tat on his
back he's got a Nixon poster he's got
Nixon uh uh memorabilia in his office
that he does his show on he loves
criminal president's game he loves
criminal presidents I mean it takes one
to no one right right like he loves
criminals because he's like ah ah that
is my people well listen to what he's
about to what his plan is if Trump can't
win the election listen
what they're assuming is that the
election will be normal the election
will not be normal oh these are the
California results sorry we're not
accepting that we're challenging them in
court if the electors show up at the
collect at the Electoral College armed
guards will throw them out I'm the
president you you're not stealing
Florida you're not stealing I'm
challenging all of it and the judges
we're going to are Judges I appointed
you're not stealing the election that's
what that basically what Bush did to
gore
so it you know if they want to run a
bunch of fake ballots we'll have an
investigation we'll say these ballots
are fake your results are invalidated
goodbye that's the way it's going to
have to look well it's gonna be really
nasty wow but you cannot count on we're
not going to get an honest selection
right so let's say the Trump is a little
behind right now which he probably is
that doesn't bother me but even if he
wins an honest election we're not going
to have an honesty on it they're going
to steal they're still in this blind in
Florida right now
so you know it's not the first time it's
happened in this country it happens
around the world yeah so he's going to
have to he's going to have to fight for
the presidency in the courts our next
election will be decided in the courts
because they cheat and we don't cheat
we've never cheated
oh [ __ ] me there's so much to unpack in
this absolute delusional rant I again I
don't know if he's snorting Nixon's ass
here but holy [ __ ]
he's like look listen listen it's going
to be in the courts okay it's gonna be
it's gonna be it's gonna be in the
courts okay like can you imagine these
guys trying to film this thing with this
guy I I can imagine losing his mind
these are I think what they're Dutch
filmmakers or Danish filmmakers um yeah
I think so and so they're in the they're
they're probably there listening like I
think they're Dutch I think they're
Dutch oh right yeah like they're they're
they don't want to challenge what he's
saying they're just like yeah keep
talking keep talking so they're like oh
oh we're oh we we don't know how that is
in America they're like whoa you're a
[ __ ] you're alive dude yeah I mean
here's the thing like amped up [ __ ]
right man like when you're when you're a
documentary filmmaker or and a content
creator in general yeah like I I would
love I would love to have Roger Stone on
this show and have him absolutely lose
his [ __ ] mind on air nothing would
please me more than to have Roger Stone
come on the show and get him on camera
losing his [ __ ] mind yeah that is a
dream come true Trump anyone else why do
you think these Trader news networks
hand these people on yeah because
they're like Jesus You're Gonna Come on
here and admit to Crime yeah come on
[ __ ] yeah hell yeah come on this will be
great this would be great content but
here you have these filmmakers now I'm
not sure what the context is like what
the direction of this documentary is but
I know Roger Stone basically will almost
agree to any documentary that is about
him
so I'm guessing this is a documentary
about him well I think from what we've
seen it is like it's a storm foretold
you know it is talking about this
election because I think what's
Happening Here is they're like hey we
want to make a documentary about you
right or with you or whatever and what
Roger Stone the reason they come up with
a title probably is because Roger Stone
is like here's all the [ __ ] we're gonna
do right to make it not a real thing I
mean he brings up Gore versus Bush and
he's like Bush was the one who appointed
the judges and made sure no I mean that
basically that basically is not even
close to what I am I mean like anyone
wants to go look up at the Brooks
Brothers Riot feel free to read about
that [ __ ] that he pulled right which is
Roger Stone which is Roger Stone one of
the reasons that the the people who are
coming about like [ __ ] this man I'm not
doing this anymore because I don't want
to be under attack people who are just
doing their jobs right like uh the the
the uh the people who are doing their
jobs in Georgia and got defamed because
of trump and and Rudy Giuliani like
these people are just trying to do their
job they're just counting the [ __ ]
ballots and they have to do it by hand
and when you come in [ __ ] raiding the
place and causing a [ __ ] show they're
like you know what my life my sanity my
safety is not worth it because you guys
don't want to uh say that you lost
because you're a sore loser right well
but even even the bush Gore thing okay
because really honestly if it was the
same thing or basically which it's not
even close number one we're talking
about eight million votes yeah overall
and we're not talking about one Precinct
that was in question here we're not
talking about one one Precinct that was
in question in one state
he Joe Biden stomped his ass across the
board and the only reason why is because
he's a failure he's a [ __ ] loser and
that's why Joe Biden absolutely killed
him is because your guy is a [ __ ]
loser and stone knows and this months
before in this rager that he's having
yeah where he's all hopped up on God
knows what I don't know if he's sniffing
again I don't know if he's sniffing
Trump's ashes or or Nixon's ashes are
Trump's ass but this this absolute rager
here he's laying out exactly and it
seems like he's he's talked to someone
about this and they're starting to plan
of what is going to happen because he
this is not just some dude
this is not just some [ __ ] dude this
guy is really good friends with the
Cheeto dust mobster not only that the
craziest part about this clip is this
this piece of footage happened the day
before
Donald Trump commute commutes this
[ __ ] sentence right I mean like
it is all in the same timeline of of how
Roger Stone and what they're projecting
their plan is to protect Trump and to
protect themselves from Criminal
prosecution if Trump loses which they
know he's gonna do right and the other
the other thing too is like he brings up
the point which I think is funny and
even funnier right now with the whole
Mar-A-Lago document situation that's
going on
Roger Stone said it'll be decided in the
courts it'll be decided in the course
they're legitimate when they right
they're legitimate maybe Trump appointed
judges so the judges that Trump put in
there everyone on the Republican side
and legitimate for Trump were like hey
look if we put them in there we can use
them later and so then Rudy Giuliani
with all his theories but no evidence
and Jen Alice a former uh uh uh uh
parking ticket uh lawyer right or or
traffic court or whatever well I mean
you know she she's she's she's got the
stench of Rudy on right but these are
the people that were like oh we're gonna
have it look at all these affidavits as
they hold up a bunch of blank paper it
the [ __ ] Kraken is coming right you
know and even even Rusty even Rusty
Bowers like well just show it to me and
they're like it's just it's just we
don't have them and here's the thing
it's the same type of thing that like
with J.R Majewski they're like just show
us the [ __ ] photos the documents show
us that you were actually there and he's
like it's all classified so when you
come back to this moment you have Roger
Stone insane oh no the courts are going
to decide this it's going to be the
Trump appointed judges that do so and
then you look at actually how the Trump
appointed judges decided they were like
if you don't have the evidence and you
can't show us that there's actual proof
that they committed voter fraud or
election fraud then I'm going to throw
this out and that's what they did they
tossed that [ __ ] out and said come back
if you have anything and they said well
we don't have anything we don't have it
well they didn't because that's the same
reason when you've got right now you've
got
um the tropical Trump appointed judge uh
Eileen Cannon says oh yeah Trump has the
ability to take these documents they're
his and then the Trump appointed judges
across the country were like that's nope
not how it works like look well in the
11th circuit the 11th circuit when they
when they slam dunked
um Cannon's opinion in the trash and she
talked tails and runs said you know
you're right I've rethought it yeah yeah
I was wrong you're right you're right
because she still wants to be a federal
judge yeah she still wants that judge
she's probably not going to be a judge
for very long this This Moment by
doubling down in the Trump Camp to say
oh those documents that were classified
those nuclear documents that should
never have left actually skipped
locations those are trumps and then once
she said that she'll never be able to
come out of that everyone's gonna know
her right as the Trump judge Lackey that
did what he said it'll be did not
actually uphold the rule of law she'll
be lucky for the bench to to put her
anywhere near a court
um speaking of federal courts today we
have uh the jury selection in the
federal trial of seditious conspiracy to
overthrow our election of Oath Keepers
founder Stewart Rhodes here is a uh an
interview that was pulled
um after this is this is in I think
December 12th I believe is the date on
this 2020 this is after the
certification
um in the states listen to Al Stewart
describes what he's gonna do see if it
sounds familiar to you
uh well we're here to help with security
we help do the PSD with General Flynn
we're working with the first amendment
potarian guard good guys and we're here
to keep everyone safe I'm speaking I'm
going to just tell people the reality is
is President Trump as commander-in-chief
has one last chance now that he's been
betrayed by the Supreme Court the
chi-coms have infiltrated this entire
country from top to bottom but he still
has the powers commander-in-chief to do
two things yeah and he has absolute
power to classify anything he wants to
no he classify all the dirty secrets in
the NSA CIA FBI files and expose all the
traders in this country all those who
have bought and sold to communist China
and two you should drop the Hammer with
the Insurrection act and wage war
against the Insurrection that's going on
in our country at this last chance
because if he doesn't do the
Insurrection we're already at war with
China we're at war with China through
their proxies here inside the United
States and Biden okay I would imagine
that that during this Stuart Rhodes
trial I would imagine for some reason it
feels like this little clip here is
going to come up and try them yeah it
just feels like he's calling for Trump
to
um Institute the interaction act to
cause war and violence like some dude
might just say you know what maybe I
should have a stash of weapons across
the Potomac when they're certifying the
vote and we could cause I don't know A
disruption and declare martial law the
Insurrection act we could arrest members
of Congress and he could overturn the
government it really seems like that was
their [ __ ] plan yeah I know I I can't
even I can't even tell you why it's so
important that Roger Stone saying what
he said in the clip I showed you before
four months before the election and here
is his co-conspirator Stewart Rhodes who
is going to be on trial his oath keep
folks Oath Keepers lieutenants who
Stuart Rhodes
had Authority in their little lost
little brains and delusional little uh
cosplay
over them was protecting Roger Stone the
day that they had the qrf waiting for
Trump to do the Insurrection act and now
we know that Stewart Rhodes was looking
for an intermediary and there were
several Communications with the Trump
White House one of them being the lady
who is the head of Latinos for Trump
who in advance had contact with the
white house and then showed up in the
goddamn parking girl garage with Stuart
Rhodes the guy saying we're gonna go to
war we're going to commit violence we'll
have him do the Insurrection act the day
before January 6th with Enrique tario
the leader of the proud boys who was not
even supposed to be there and they were
they were [ __ ] planning for the next
day of what was going to happen and the
security switches from the proud boys to
The Oath Keepers with Roger Stone as
Roger Stone four months before the
election is in her interview with a
documentary
just knowing that he's going to be
commuted his sentence is going to be
Community next day feeling feeling that
he there's nothing that can stop him
there's nothing that's going to stop
Trump they're going to take over this
country and they're going to put all
their enemies in prison like they should
be it really is telling it really is
telling and let me tell you something I
think tomorrow the January 6th select
committee is going to draw these dots
that I'm drawing now you know and God
forbid they use the rhetoric that I'm
you know God forbid they actually
politicize the [ __ ] I mean if they want
to you know I mean I will I'm going to I
would love you know get a Benny Thompson
what the [ __ ] you know kind of moment
what was that can you
that Jamie were asking in the microphone
does Gabe Sanchez and says what what was
that what was that what was it what was
that oh man speaking of what was that do
you have this uh I did and then I then I
took it down we don't have time we'll do
it we'll do it okay we'll do it on
Thursday we'll do it on Thursday so
everyone look for the what was that
we'll try to get the link because now
that we have our account I can upload
the other two on the Channel yes that's
great yes so we can upload them we can
post them there
um and make sure you follow the Tony
Michaels podcast YouTube channel as you
know we're on a seven day ban but we're
back baby we're back and we're better
than ever I mean until another Patrol
the taxes probably yeah uh but that's
just how that's just how content
creation works so go follow us
everywhere especially on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod we will try to get you out
the what was that link there also go
follow the what was that Twitter account
we need to get that we need a graphic
for that thing oh yeah did you gotta
what was that Twitter account and go to
Gabe Sanchez go to at I am Gabe Sanchez
on Twitter and he's got that link there
to go to the what was that because
they'll be posted there too you'll post
now the Links there also download every
single episode of the Tony Michaels
podcast every single weekday Monday
through Friday on Apple Spotify and
Google make sure make sure to leave us a
great review while you're there
subscribing on your favorite directory
and don't forget to follow us on Twitch
and go to Tony Michaels dot live and
watch there you can watch live every
single weekday and also while you're
there you can leave a tip or you can go
to tonymichaels.lamp slash tip you can
leave a one-time tip you can set it up
to do it monthly if you'd like to
support Pro democracy speech support our
show I mean Gabe work hard over here
we're not bragging or anything
uh but we try to work hard for our
democracy we try to bring you every
single weekday a place where you can
come to get cathartic relief from these
[ __ ] fascists and discover
why why you should engage in your
democracy why you should lean into it
and make sure that you save democracy
because it is up to you it's us it's us
baby also to support the show you can
like spread it around spread that link
around but man this merch store these
people are loving this merch game the
Downy merch stickers t-shirts hoodies
this one's a big one the Rhonda Santas
can go [ __ ] himself we've also talked
about another one yes yeah we're gonna
release some uh probably next week I
think we'll get some next week that
everyone's gonna love it's a famous
phrase of mine or a couple famous
phrases of mine that we're gonna put on
some T-shirts so be looking be looking
for those brand new designs at
store.dtonymichaels.com but Gabe there's
nothing that compares to this one this
design here the dark brand new design
dark Brandon
oh this this exclusive Tony Michael's
Design is flying off the shelves so if
you want to support our show and have a
little something to wear
don't forget to get your dark Brandon
hoodie it's getting cold out there go to
store.doney michaels.com and warm up
with your dark Brandon hoodie and
support democracy pro-democracy speech
everywhere again you can go to Tony
Michaels dot live you can find the tip
jar there you can also go the sandwich
icon you can find
you can find the uh we're gonna have
some great sponsors too here soon yeah
you can find that well [ __ ] them hats I
get the [ __ ] them answers right here you
see in the background and we can you got
the merch store so go go find all those
links on Tony michaels.live and make
sure to bookmark that son of a [ __ ] in
case we get banned who knows who knows
what can happen when you have the Deep
state after you ah who knows man I don't
know isn't it that's just gonna get that
Soros advertising money yeah that's
that's you know there's gonna be a 30
second spot dedicated George Soros and
it's gonna be like thanks to George
Soros I was able to build my life back
from nothing
we should we should do a uh a spoof
commercial the the George George Soros
money train or something like that you
know where you sign up to be antifa you
got you got to go to the you got to go
to the weekly meetings yeah yeah it's
important and and at our antifa I don't
know about your chapter out there in
California but our antifa chapter here
and Missouri you got to bring chocolate
chip cookies it is a requirement oh yeah
we bring s'mores out here oh okay so
that's a little different out there yeah
we heat them up you know put them
together it's all good well and you
can't go to the grocery store and get
those [ __ ] pre-made Chips Ahoy [ __ ]
oh you got you got homemade ass
chocolate bacon cookies homemade
chocolate ass chip cookies you cannot
you cannot have some slacking ass [ __ ]
this is antifa God damn it we're serious
about the chocolate chip cookies and
pro-democracy Smith everybody we need
sweets we do to keep us going to fight
fascism you know oh yeah little little
known Secret free for the people out
there listening and watching right uh
chocolate chip cookies actually fuel
anti-fascists it does it does chocolate
chip cookies are the anti-fascist snack
so everyone tomorrow uh one more
announcement before we go tomorrow we're
going to be live at the same exact time
same exact place Newton Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific for the hearing so
we're going to do an hour of commentary
at our normal time here on the Tony
Michaels podcast we will be broadcasting
it live here so you can go to subscribe
to the D Tony Michaels podcast if you
want to watch it here or you can go to
the mind to touch Network channel And
subscribe on the minus touch networks
channel uh we'll be airing live over
there as well but we were same time same
place tomorrow but we will have the
hearing so not quite as many fuckems
yeah unfortunately little we're gonna
have a lot of guests though maybe post
maybe post hearing there's some fuckems
oh yeah absolutely but before light on
the [ __ ] I think I think I've got um on
the panel just to let everyone know we
get uh politics girly McGowan I've got
our favorite the best political
strategist in the world right
at some point I've got Jessica Denson
the in the Trump NDA killer I got the
Midas Mighty favorite Texas Paul
um I'm working on Michael Cohen I think
let's see who else do we we have David
Bender another great uh political
commentator David he wears his uh Fedora
that's right we have the legal AF the
legal a effers here we're gonna have uh
Karen at niblo and we're also gonna have
Michael popock so join us tomorrow then
the whole slate Avengers
just talking head pundits that's right
that's right that's right we're gonna
we're gonna kick ass and take names
tomorrow so everyone tune in tomorrow
same time same place don't forget to set
your reminder and until then Surf's Up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon soon in the meantime follow
Tony on social media at the Tony
Michaels and until next time raise a
fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
IES Beacon